if your YouTube views have been going
down you're not alone I was reading a
book recently called decisive and one of
the strategies for making better
decisions is attain distance before
deciding so the first thing I would
suggest when seeing a slump in views on
your channel is attaining distance
getting a 30 000 foot perspective and
asking some questions could the degrees
and Views be related to seasonality
attaining distance could also look like
asking yourself what is the landscape of
my Niche and topic how has that changed
for some seasoned creators you maybe
have been consistently creating content
year after year but now your views are
going down well chances are there could
be more creators and more options around
that type of content today and as a
result maybe the views are being
distributed across multiple channels